well speaking of characters on kill Tony
uh you know I actually think that one of
them actually showed up Jesus it's
actually one of your favorite character
let me Oh let me go grab her oh my gosh
I can't believe that you you came
prepared
okay ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
the podcast feminist Stacey how long did
it take for you to get a woman on your
show on the show okay it's an odd number
it's easy pink here today huh Stacey
it's always pink feminist Eric Griffin I
think you're so big in your royal castle
with your brick wall and ooh I've been
on TV look at me oh here's my special
subtly on the table right in front of a
guest yeah look it up the ugly truth
DVD you could buy it on my website Thank
You feminist and also get it plugs I
can't believe that you you brought
Jeremiah wonders to my listen there may
be saxophone playing later I don't know
but all I need all I need for you to
know is that feminist Stacey is actually
a big fan of riffing with Griffin oh
really
yeah I love your voice my voice yes so
tell me an episode that you enjoyed the
most feminist station I like a lot of
the solo episodes where you really just
go off the rails that's a good answer
so are you hear anything coming in the
pipeline would ya I'm blogging
constantly what's the then this Stacey's
blog
obviously it's obviously pretty simple
to search for on the internet just
feminist a 70 high-seas blog no video no
it's all transcription of conversations
that I have so you better watch yourself
mister so there doesn't be a me-too
moment at living with Griffin wait so
now let me ask you so do you record the
conversation so you may be at Starbucks
you record the conversation recording
everything right now I know I'm on your
podcast but watch out mister I'm
recording you with my cell phone I can't
believe you did this to me then you
trace then I transcribe it
you're the work you're the worst
legitimately you had a great moment a
guy at one of the shows and I said
something that you said something to me
and then all of a sudden you put that on
the internet I mean yeah yeah you can
type it in on YouTube feminist AC yes
I'm gonna have to put that in the
description of episode will people can
really know who the dominant one is
happy may not feminist AC is your very
um you know are you dating I mean are
you trying to court oh now I feel me too
oh really well finally you share the
feeling that all the women have you know
what I've got to go alright Eric Griffin
how are you ever think that everybody
thinks that feminist AC for coming on
feminist AC out like I can't believe
let's get Jeremiah back oh there he is
yeah I can't believe she interrupted the
show like that dude I brought her she's
been waiting in the wings the whole time
so I
I apologize uh but she can't be silenced
she's told me that too many times